we were backstage and we started to talk
about Kevin kids and our kids are
getting older I think your kids are
older than mine
19 and 14 girls 19 and and and how are
they because my daughter is younger than
that but I hear it starts to get tricky
how is it going with girls that age it
turns yeah you know the love you feel
from your daughter right now yes soon
that'll be gone I just I don't know it
changes they get hormones I Drive to
school with my daughter and she won't
talk to me it's like a 15 20 minute
drive and she just look out the window
and then if I try to talk to her she's
like dad don't you know when you try to
talk to me what all this is about music
that's my pet peeve we have to sit in
quiet the whole time and she doesn't
think I'm funny but like just such an
extent that it's deeply hurtful right
and she said it's really seriously she's
not joking she's like dad I hate your
jokes so much that sometimes my friends
make jokes which are funny but I don't
laugh cuz you make jokes she's saying
she's saying your comedy is so horrible
to her it is ruined all comedy turn it
and then if anyone likes me right that
bugs are too so I'm the rare moment that
someone walks up to me and is like hey I
like to knocked up it really made me
happy the second they walk away she
mocks them and she was like I really
enjoyed you feel I mean I you know she
keeps calling me this name that's really
harsh might be true though like the
other day I was calling to get a
reservation at a restaurant now
one out of 20 They Know Who I am and
they'll be nice to me but I still go for
it every time
and I'll say hi this is John Apatow you
got room for two at 8 o'clock and as
soon as I hang up my daughter always
turns to me and goes what a Hollywood
dick
there's no waiting there's nobody
there's a photo I brought a photo of my
sorry I'm looking at you this is there a
look that's captured so much I'm yeah
it's like the Mona Lisa yeah
you know what it is I like that there's
disdain in the foreground and hate in
the back
you